I hear a scratching
I opened my eyes and I look over the bed
and I can see her even in the dark
I can see her eyes my little best friend
Kaylee she's a white Lhasa Apso
and if you own a dog you know that even
though they don't speak English they can
talk to you with their eyes and I can
see even in the dark what she's trying
to tell me she has to pee
and I'm surprised because she's not a
middle of the night P kind of dog so I
look at my phone I see it's two o'clock
I realize I have to bring her out and
now I have a decision to make
I'm wearing a pair of satin boxers
covered in a purple and red hearts my
mother-in-law gave them to me for
Valentine's Day in fact I tried to
forget every time I put them on
but I have to decide if I'm gonna get
dressed and bring her out or if I'm just
going to run her out and get back to bed
as quick as I can
it's warm and I live on one of these
streets that you only drive on if you
live on there's a dozen houses I know
everybody they're all in bed it's two
o'clock I decide this will be fine
I slide some slippers on and we head for
the door when we get to the stairs I
pick Kaylee up about 10 years ago she
had emergency emergency spinal surgery
that she wasn't supposed to survive and
if she did survive she was supposed to
never walk again and she beat both of
those odds but she's never done stairs
ever since and so I always hold her
close and I bring her up and down every
stair she ever has to climb
and so when I get to the bottom of the
stairs I hook the leash on and we go out
onto the lawn and she starts to find a
spot it's a warm night it's dark there's
not a star or moon in the sky and the
birds are loud they're like riotous
and I'm waiting for her to pee and
finally she dies and I turn to go back
in and she pulls on the leash and I look
she wants to walk to the end of the
street and she doesn't walk very much
anymore and I want to go to bed so I'm
like come on and she gives me another
look with her eyes it's the look that
says don't be an
and so I say fine it's like a hundred
yards down the road it'll be fine and so
in my underwear and slippers I begin
walking my dog down the road
I really can't say no to Kaylee ever
anyway when we got her I was married to
another woman it was my practice
marriage and
when my ex-wife said let's get a dog I
said no because I will fall in love and
you have no follow-through and so you
will abandon the dog and want to get rid
of it and it will become between us and
that's exactly what happened in honesty
the marriage would have eventually
Fallen apart anyway but truly Kelly got
me out of that marriage at least a year
before I would have and that meant that
I got to meet the woman who I love today
the woman of my dreams and I would have
not been in a position to meet her at
that time had it not been for my dog my
friend and so I have a hard time saying
no
and so we finally get to the end of the
street and I turn to head back and she
pulls again and I look and she's already
rounding the corner she doesn't walk
around the block and I am in my
underwear and I want to go to bed
so I said come on really and she's
already going
and this next street will be fine too
nobody drives on this street but the
third street is Main Street in Newington
Connecticut there will be cars and
trucks and cops everyone will be on that
street
but I see guys run around in shorts and
no shirt and I know I don't look like
any of those guys but maybe
maybe that's the goal maybe that's why
I'm out at two o'clock in the morning so
I don't subject people to this
and so I decide to walk around the block
in my underwear with my dog
we turn the right on Main Street I'm now
as far away from my house as I can be on
this block and it is that moment when
one second ago it was not raining and
now the biblical blood flood all the
rain in the world just instantly falls
down upon me and now I know why there
were no stars in the sky and why the
birds were making a racket like I get it
and I start to think maybe she did this
too Kaylee because she used to love to
run in the rain we both did we would run
everywhere in the rain and we haven't
done it in years and I'm mad now like I
realize she has tricked me and so I bend
over to pick her up and I see a look on
her face that I don't see very much
anymore she is smiling she has that
tongue out of her mouth smile
and I have this moment where I realize
that my dog is 16 years old and she I
know in my heart isn't doing very well
and this might be the last time in my
life and in her life that we ever walk
in the rain together
and so I stop
and I stand upright
and I stand in my underwear
becoming like disturbingly plastered on
my parts
but I stand there for 5 10 15 minutes I
wait until she is ready to go
before we leave
Kaylee died three months ago
and on that corner that night it turns
out I was wrong and I was right
I was wrong to think she didn't have a
lot of time left because she had two
more years two
glorious years that I had with my best
friend
but I was right too because it was the
last time we ever walked in the rain
together that night in my underwear
except
honestly until this very second it does
not occur to me but
tonight right here for one second
you all went away and this went away
and that's storytelling for one second I
was back on that corner with my friend
who I miss every day of my life
and I could see her smiling at me as
clear as day
and maybe you could too I hope you could
because she was beautiful
and she was perfect
and every morning that I wake up
I look for her before realizing that
she's gone
and so if you could see her
I'm glad and
I saw her tonight and for that I thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]